-Hey, guys, I'm about to
show you some books
that you should avoid
at all costs.
It is time for the latest
installment of my
"Do Not Read" list.
♪ Do not read ♪
♪ Do not read these books ♪
♪ These books ♪
-Now, before we start,
I just want you to know that
every book that I'm about to
show you is 100% real.
These are actual books.
You can find them on Amazon
or check them out
at your local library.
They are real.
Alright, let's see what's on
my "Do Not Read" list.
This first one here is a book
for all of you animal lovers.
This is called "Hamsters for
Pleasure and Profit."
-Come on.
-I bet this has your usual
advice on how to
make money off
your hamsters, but who knows.
Let's take a look in here.
Oh. Hmm.
It says, "Begin!
Lose this day loitering,
'twill be the same old story,
tomorrow, and the next day
more dilatory.
Each indecision brings
its own delays,
and days are lost
lamenting o'er lost days.
What you can do,
or think you can, begin it.
Boldness has genius,
power, and magic in it!"
That is a quote by the
famous 17th century German
writer Goethe.
Again, this is "Hamsters for
Pleasure and Profit."
[ Laughter ]
Next up is a photography book.
I love those ones.
This one is
called "Women in Trees."
It is literally 100-plus pages
of old photos of random women
sitting in trees.
And in case that
wasn't enough for you,
they came out with
"More Women in Trees."
Yeah.
That's actually more of a stump.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, sequels are
never as good.
Next is a paranormal book.
It's perfect for Halloween.
This is...
"Enjoy Your Own Funeral."
Sounds like a fun thing to do.
Look at these two people.
They're clearly having a blast.
You should be able to
enjoy your funeral.
It's your day, you know?
-Yeah.
-Why should everyone else
have all the fun?
[ Laughter ]
Why let everyone else
have the fun?
Next is a book called...
"Is Eating People Wrong?"
I'm gonna save you
the time reading this.
Uh, yes.
I'm not sure what category
this next book belongs in,
but this is...
"This Man Touched Me."
-Come on.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. But you know what's
even crazier, though?
Shocking about this.
No one checked it out.
Well, we're down to
our last book.
-Oh, man.
-Well, it has --
You know, all good things.
-Yeah.
-This is an autobiography.
Yep.
This is called...
"A Tramp Finds a Home."
[ Laughter ]
Let's just hope she doesn't
live next to this guy.
There you go.
That's all I have for
this edition of my
"Do Not Read" list.
If you have a book that
you think should be
on our next "Do Not Read" list,
I want to see it.
Send your titles to
donotread@tonightshow.com.